straight ahead on lawn crime daily
an accused serial killer is trying to
represent himself
the dna used to catch him and the
evidence he says
clears his name police officers in
rochester new york accused of pepper
spraying a nine-year-old girl
what led up to this incident and the
response afterwards
plus a black man shot and killed by an
atlanta police officer
why the prosecutor of the rayshard
brooks case now wants the trial
moved out of her county and from escaped
inmates
to captured fugitives the tip that led
arizona law enforcement
to their wanted men law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everybody to long crime daily
i'm jesse weber along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin
only a snowstorm would keep brian out of
the studio so i hope everyone doesn't
mind me filling in for today but
let's get started a suspected serial
killer in florida is trying to get one
of his cases thrown out
and he's doing it by himself and
jeannette levy is here with details on
that request
yeah jesse this is the 13-page
handwritten motion
that robert hayes has filed in his palm
beach county case
in it he claims that prosecutors
withheld evidence
that would help him defend himself
suspected serial killer robert hayes in
quarantine
appeared via zoom in a palm beach county
courtroom just briefly
he'd hoped to make his case but there
were technical issues
mr hayes i thought in the past that the
deputies had the ability to
to do something with the hardware out
there to get you to activate the
microphone but that's not the case
hayes is accused of murdering rachel bay
in 2016 by strangling her
palm beach county deputies say a rape
kit revealed hayes dna so we have rachel
bay's dna
and robert hayes dna it's more likely
that the dna sample is
rachel bay and robert hayes than rachel
bay and any other human on the planet
genetic genealogy solved bay's murder
and linked haze to the murders of three
more women in daytona beach from 2005 to
2006.
those women had been shot to death had
we not done this
we're pretty sure that he would have
killed again hayes has pleaded not
guilty and in his motion to dismiss
he claims investigators withheld cell
phone information
that showed he was in a different area
from the location of the murder
at the same time a witness allegedly
told police he
saw bay alive hayes admits to having sex
with rachel bay that night
but claims he didn't kill her
investigators disagree
we have been able to take what we
believe is a serial killer off the
streets
and robert hayes will be back in court
in palm beach county later this month to
argue
his motion to dismiss prosecutors down
in volusia county where
the other murders happened are seeking
the death penalty
they say that he targeted prostitutes
for many years
jesse let's break it down uh brian
this is a very interesting case for a
lot of reasons but right now he's
requesting something called a nelson
hearing
what exactly is this and how does it
typically play out
yeah so jesse a nelson hearing in
florida is an inquiry that the defendant
would ask the judge and say hey
i don't think that this guy or girl next
to me that being the lawyer is doing a
good enough job
job i think they're ineffective and i
may want to represent myself
in a nelson hearing the judge will have
a searching inquiry to see both what's
going on between the lawyer
and the defendant and will make a
decision as to whether or not that
lawyer is ineffective and whether or not
they should be replaced
terry this one's a bit different for a
lot of reasons but hayes drafts this
handwritten motion
i mean what did you think of that i
actually
read the handwritten motion and i was
impressed
you know he has a degree in criminal
justice and it actually
shows he used well-formed sentences
there weren't any
misspellings he used legalese i mean for
instance one of the things he said was
it's well documented by the superior
court
that all agents and the government like
the prosecution or the police
have a perpetual burden to provide
exculpatory evidence to the accused
that's quite well written and he formed
these
arguments that were well formed so kudos
to him
well antoinette we have him charged in
relation to four
women but my understanding is there's a
potential other victim stacy gage
shot dead as well he didn't get charged
in connection with her death
why is that and what do we know about
how that could affect his current case
yeah we don't really know how it could
impact the current prosecutions
in volusia county and palm beach county
but we know that police were actively
investigating at the time that the
indictment was announced they were still
actively investigating his connection to
stacy gage's murder
now her body had decomposed quite a bit
by the time it was found but she was
also
shot with the same caliber of weapon as
the other three victims in volusia
county so
you know they there's a connection there
they've said he is connected to that
crime but whether or not they'll ever be
able to get the evidence to actually
charge him in that case that just
remains to be seen
yeah it's a disturbing case to follow
it's gonna be interesting to see which
way it ultimately carries out
let's switch gears though because rock
legend rod stewart
and his son are reportedly expected to
take a plea deal in a simple battery
case out of florida
the palm beach police department says
the singer and his son got into an
altercation at the breakers beach resort
on new year's eve in 2019
the two reportedly weren't allowed into
a party when sean stewart
shoved a security guard and the rock
star threw a punch
now security footage apparently captured
the incident but that has
not yet been made public a hearing has
been set for march
26th when the case is likely to be
resolved
former los angeles dodgers pitcher scott
erickson is facing a charge of reckless
driving
and a hit-and-run crash that killed two
boys last year
the l.a county sheriff's office says a
family of six was crossing the road
around 7 pm on september 29
2020. the mother saw two speeding cars
and was able to grab two of her children
tragically though two brothers eight and
eleven years old
were struck and killed the drivers fled
and one was arrested and charged with
murder and vehicular manslaughter
the sheriff's office says that erickson
was the second driver
he's scheduled to be arraigned on march
16th and we'll see where that goes
all right still ahead on law and crime
daily a prosecutor's request
to move a high-profile case out of her
office
but first the disturbing video of a
young girl handcuffed held down
and pepper sprayed the police response
and calls for action
next
[Music]
newly released police body cam video
shows officers restraining a
nine-year-old girl handcuffing her and
spraying her
with pepper spray nine rochester new
york police officers responded to a call
of family trouble on friday
officials say that they were told the
girl was suicidal the officers are seen
on camera trying to get the girl into a
patrol
car but she repeatedly kicked and pulled
at them
that's when an officer is heard saying
quote just spray her at this point
the girl actually cries out for her
father now here's the video and we warn
you
it is disturbing you're not gonna run
away from me okay cause i'm gonna have
to chase you
okay and i got like six other cars
coming to chase you i don't care
all right well come and talk to me
[Music]
here just stop for a second
please getting the snow off of me oh
i'll get the snow off you guys guys
you had your chance get in the car now
okay
okay you've had your chances what are
you doing
what are you doing i want you you're
gonna go to jail now
stop
my
unbelievable wow
that's tough to watch uh brian i have to
ask you the use of pepper spray you know
as opposed to some other means
could it be necessary here when you're
dealing with non-compliance but you are
dealing with non-compliance
of a juvenile not an adult
so jesse from a legal standpoint the law
would actually say
pepper spray is much like any other use
of force and it is necessary
necessary to use air quotes for
non-compliance but even in the video
when you see this young girl and they're
yelling at her because they're annoyed
they're frustrated
they're saying stop acting like a child
and she rightfully yells back
i am a child and it boils down again to
officers
feeling that they can use force when
someone is not following their
instruction it's a
nine-year-old girl crying for her father
and you're gonna pepper spray her into
compliance
that should not be legal that needs to
change well terry should the
police have even responded because
reportedly this girl was suicidal were
they the appropriate department to come
there
well you hit it on the head jesse no
they were not the appropriate department
to respond
they should have sent a mental health
crisis
response team because if she were
suicidal
there should be someone to talk to her
not to handcuff her
pepper spray her throw her in the car
and
the other thing is they should be
thinking about the mental development of
a child
versus an adult there have been many
studies to show
that adults are very different than
children children are not just little
adults and you have to deal with them
separately and differently so this was
horrible on so many levels and it was
extremely difficult
to watch the way they responded to this
nine-year-old little girl
brian real quick 30 seconds what could
happen to the officers involved in this
incident
more likely than not there's going to be
a civil suit perhaps they'll be off duty
but like i said
they follow the books in the sense that
the law and the procedures allow them to
do this for non-compliance
but of course there's a growing pushback
on the use of force especially against
young children
this could change in new york city and
it's just fascinating that this was all
caught on camera now everybody sees it i
mean i haven't seen a video like that
it's really
really disturbing all right coming up on
long crime daily
while the process why the prosecutor
overseeing one of the rachard brooks
case
is asking him for it to be moved out of
her office
plus two inmates go from wanted
fugitives to newly booked into the
county jail
the statewide manhunt and the tip that
led investigators to their big break
still ahead
[Music]
welcome back everybody the newly elected
district attorney overseeing the rachard
brooks case
wants it off her workload and
transferred to another prosecuting
attorney
officials say brooks was shot and killed
last summer in a wendy's parking lot by
atlanta police officer garrett rolfe
rolfe is awaiting trial on murder and
aggravated assault charges
district attorney fawni willis beat out
incumbent paul howard last year
and she reportedly is now asking the
georgia attorney general's office
to refer rolfe's case out of her office
because
howard used the case in political ads
howard was criticized for announcing his
decision to
charge the officer just five days after
the shooting
after mr brooks was shot for some period
of two minutes
and 12 seconds there was
no medical attention applied to mr
brooks
but when we examined the videotape
and in our discussions with witnesses
during the two minutes and 12 seconds
that
officer roth actually kicked mr brooks
while he laid on the ground while he was
there fighting for his life
the other officer officer brosnan
actually stood on mr brooks's shoulders
while he was there struggling for his
life the demeanor of the officers
immediately after the shooting did not
reflect
any fear or danger of mr brooks
but their actions really reflected
other kinds of emotions
all right let's get into this terry was
it the right decision by willis to have
the case transferred and who would take
over
i don't think this was the right
decision i think that no matter where
this case goes
it's going to be difficult you know the
claim is that
howard the predecessor prosecutor he
rushed to charge and he didn't use a
grand jury
he didn't wait for the georgia bureau of
investigation to finish its
investigation
and it was a very publicly tried case so
to speak
and so i think no matter where it goes
it's going to be controversial and i
think it's going to be
difficult and i think she's just
throwing a hot potato to another office
brian does the decision by willis in any
way taint or affect the prosecution of
rolf
it is going to affect i i slightly
disagree with terry and i only say
slightly because she is right the case
is tainted by the way howard dealt with
this case
and the fish kind of stinks from the
head down this
although it might be putting a band-aid
on a cancer is a
some kind of a way to redeem this office
and redeem this case
and have some fresh hands to start off
well terry what happens to howard
because i know he's facing this gbi
investigation but did he do anything
where he could face repercussions in
either a civil or ethical arena
well he definitely is facing
repercussions in an ethical arena
the ethics committee has already charged
him with over
a dozen claims i mean he's got some tax
claims related to this he's
used funds in his own personal account
so
he's definitely got some issues here
even if they aren't technically
related to this case specifically and
you know one other thing i'll say he's
also got
civil charges against him for sexual
harassment so
i think that's the whole reason he
actually lost his re-election but he's
got
a lot of charges to face here we'll be
curious to see where the case goes
because you know there's a lot of
eyeballs on what happens in atlanta
all right when we come back the manhunt
that ended in a cotton field
how police captured two escaped inmates
after a five day long chase
that's up next
two inmates are back in custody after
escaping prison and leading authorities
on a dramatic chase
authorities say david harmon and john
charpiott
broke out of an arizona state complex
prison complex last week
the pair are believed to have stolen
tools from the prison to cut through a
fence
a 70 thousand dollar reward had been
offered for their capture but they
apparently didn't
get far in five days on the run because
a local man out driving in coolidge
which is just
14 miles down the road from the prison
spotted them
in their prison ware in a cotton field
the man called 9-1-1
an agent with the u.s marshals moved it
moved it
get on the ground now
get on the ground now
okay
there we go
[Applause]
now just before they were captured the
duo are accused of attacking a woman
and trying to steal her vehicle
during the course of this investigation
and
attempt to recapture over 800 houses
were searched
in a period of 16 hours by the members
of these agencies that you see standing
here in this room
there was not a complaint there was just
just a team effort they understood how
dangerous these guys were
when you look at the record of both of
these subjects
one of them is a home invasion rapist
while the other is a molester of
children
ranging from ages seven to four years
old
these were bad people we wanted to get
off the street
the defendants were booked into the
county jail and the local prosecutor
says that more charges
are expected they would not
obey commands at one point both of them
said
just shoot me they're both asking uh for
uh the coolidge petty officers and the
deputy marshals to kill them
they would run walk run walk away from
the officers
they obviously weren't in very good
shape so they weren't running very fast
or walking very fast
so at that point non-lethal electric
shock weapons were used
also known as tasers on the individuals
they were put into custody and uh and
eventually transported to
coolidge police department and then from
there for processing
and and uh further investigation i spoke
to the two
maricopa county judges who sentenced
these two individuals
uh because when when they escaped from
prison
obviously there's a major concern with
our judges who have tough jobs
and they were notified this morning that
they were into custody and
and i know they felt very relieved also
well well terry now that these men have
been apprehended what
charges could they face you know
escaping from prison that's another
criminal offense so in arizona they
could be charged with first degree
escape
because they actually injured someone in
the process and that's a class for
felony and they could be sentenced to an
additional
so it's going to be consecutive not
concurrent an
additional sentence of up to three years
and
the other thing jesse is they really
could be put
in a maximum security area now that we
know that they
try to escape and that wouldn't be so
surprising but let me ask you brian this
could be surprising because if you go to
the prison
are they legally liable for anything
after these two men escaped i mean after
all it was their
job to keep them in prison so are they
liable for anything they did on the
outside
oh the prison could absolutely be on the
hook for any kind of damage or harm that
these two
um committed when they got out there's
two ways of looking at this
cause and effect meaning but for what
the prison did
this harm like the stealing of a car
injury of an individual would not have
occurred
or what's called proximate cause you
think about like a chain of events
if you didn't do this then this would
have happened then this would have
happened and they wouldn't have stolen
my car
and those are two ways that the prison
could be liable and terry let me ask you
this you mentioned it what safeguards
need to be put in place by the prison
maybe that weren't put in there the
first time so that these two don't
escape again
well clearly they have to have increased
security procedures but you heard on the
tape there
that the police officers weren't in good
shape so
maybe one of the things we should be
doing is making sure
that these officers are in better shape
to go after these
prisoners who've escaped but yeah they
just need more
security and better security overall at
these prisons
well i'm looking at them and i'm
thinking we are never going to see them
again
on the outside at least that's what
we're all hoping for because those two
are just trouble
all right everybody thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you